enfin certains groupes terroristes
contrairement au houi àarala ne
bénéficient pas d'un soutien matériel
extérieur c'est notamment le cas de
l'armement des groupes dihadistes au
Sahel car elle a aussi beaucoup publié
sur ce sujet et nous publions à la fin
du mois trois rapports sur spécifique
spécifiquement sur l'armement des
groupes djihadistes au Sahel Niger Mali
Burkina
Faso voilà une cartographie des saisies
lié au djihadisme que nous avons
documenté dans la région vous avez en
bleu foncé notamment à droite dans le
sud-est du Niger les saisies liées à
l'état islamique en Afrique de l'Ouest
et précédemment à Boko Haram vous avez
en gris vert si j'ose dire les saisis
liées à l'état islamique au Grand Sahara
vous avez en jaune en orange excusez-moi
les saisis lié au gnim donc Al-Qaïda et
hangrie des saisies qui ont été
déterminé comme djihadistes
mais pour lesquels nous n'avons pas pu
déterminer le groupe d'appartenance qui
se divise entre ces trois grandes
branches en règle générale ce que nous
observons sur les sources
d'approvisionnement en armes et en
munition pour les groupes djihadistes au
Sahel c'est la chose suivante c'est que
la très grande partie de leur arsenal
provient du détournement de stocks
nationaux ceuxci les groupes les groupes
dihadistes pillent les stocks nationaux
ils attaquent des bases des postes de
sécurité et cetera ça répond à un double
objectif bien s s'approvisionner en
matériel mais aussi bien sûr faire
reculer l'état contrôler du
territoire les groupes djihadistes
s'approvisionnent aussi beaucoup sur un
armement qui est hérité des conflits
régionaux antérieurs il y a une certaine
porosité entre les différents conflits
donc vous pouviez avoir par exemple les
rébellions en Côte d'Ivoire ou les
insurrections ont donné lieu à de grand
d'importants circuits euh de de ou
d'importants mouvements d'armes
illicites enfin et on est là là sur une
proportion somme toute mineure et plutôt
anecdotique il y a effectivement un
armement détourn des stocks de la
jamahelia
libyenne pourquoi je note anecdotique
parce que en règle générale on entend
souvent que ces stocksl auraient
finalement été l'essentiel aurait
constitué l'essentiel de l'armement des
groupes djihadistes au sel c'est faux et
c'est de moins en moins
vrai et enfin et là nous sommes vraiment
dans l'anecdotique et dans quelques cas
à de très dans de très rares occasions
les groupes djihadistes vont
s'approvisionner sur les marchés noirs
c'est extrêmement rare ils ne souhaite
pas dépenser d'argent pour cela et en
règle générale lorsqu'on a documenté des
cas similaires c'était plutôt des
individus qui étaient djihadistes en
soirée bandit de grand chemin en matinée